接下来我们要进入的是30天
课程里面的第二大段
歌词创作中的基本训练很重要
像练拳不练功到老一场空
你听过吧
什么意思
有时候看你武侠片有没有
就是他们在打套路
然后这个人好像拿了个武林秘籍之后呢
打来打套路练
然后几个近卫交代之后
他就可以出去江湖闯荡
我一直百思不得其解
你知道吗
你没有做重力训练嘛
但重力训练拍起来不戏剧嘛
所有的重力训练是类似可能伏地挺身啊
然后做一些跑步啊
然后做一些体力上的磨练
那通常一些武侠片他不加在这个过程
我都对我来讲了
别人别人别人是怎么想
不晓得那对我来讲就缺一个真实感
你没有重力训练的状况下
你的肌耐力
你有办法一拳打过去
这个人会受伤吗
或是这个人打你挡过去
他手会痛吗
你怎么能只学套路呢
我看就就不真实
就是他只学里面的招数
我们不能只有写歌词
而应该了解说哦
歌词的韵脚怎么使用
韵脚的使用在哪个关键点换
韵脚如何换
甚至于去经营文字美感的时候
如何用下一行去呼应上一行
用文字的对仗去营造他视觉上的一个美感
今天分享的课程是如何欣赏一首好歌词
同学们记住哦
我们上的是歌词创作班
所以呢如何欣赏一首好歌词是基本的条件
就像你上的是电影班一样
那起码你要能分辨这个电影的好坏
好在哪里
我还剪接的很节奏很明快
它的配乐有加大分
他的灯光
他的一个场景的布置
所以电影奖项里面分的很细
还有分最佳摄影
最佳剧本
然后最佳导演
那还有最佳剪接
就像音乐一样
他可能有最佳作词作曲
然后最佳的编曲
所以呢每个独立的项目都是可以拉开来
独立的去鉴赏或是讨论它
那今天我们的重点是如何欣赏一首好歌词
接下来一样会有一些辅助的教材
首先我们分享的这首叫丹青千里
丹青千里是个很特别的一首歌
他就是为了一幅画创作的那幅画叫千里江山图
他是北宋时期一个天才的少年画家
他就18岁叫王希孟所传世留下来的画作
他就留下这么一幅画而已
然后它是青绿山水
不是我们熟知的墨色山水
所以呢我的歌名就是去呼应他这幅画
因为这个专案是focus在这一幅画
就叫丹青千里
还有银色的感觉
我们说到了这首丹青千里
他是由张亚东老师作曲
易烊千玺演唱
Day one
就是择人离四人骑
而丹青依旧
千里山壮丽
水秀起
墨色起谁远去
哲人跟世人
他其实是对仗山壮丽
水秀起山就是对仗水
歌词的对账
文字结构是这样子
用意境去对唱
山对水
然后远对近
所以这个是一个对仗的一个创作的方法
第二个分享的创作
这个叫菊花台
当初这首歌呃是因为先有一个电影的花絮
他这首是搭配满城尽带黄金甲写的电影主题曲
那搭配的时候你就已经先看到片花了
看到变化的时候
你就知道说哦他的重点在哪里
因为他是满城尽带黄金甲
那个黄金甲其实是整个京城都是菊花
那时候我就想来想去
我想说好吧
我就把它记忆点放在菊花这两个字
但是菊花是名词
它好像直接用名词很奇怪
后来想说啊
菊花台
因为他的宫殿里面铺满了菊花嘛
那好像台的话好像有一个集中的感觉
那像这个它是很标准的那种
L on a two b one b two
就是四大段落
我们先直接看副歌
那菊花残满地伤
你的笑容已泛黄
这首歌就是YAN跟an
然后第二个副歌是北风乱夜未央
你的影子剪不断
注意看哦
这里面的副歌其实第一行并没有重复
这个就是变化
不是所有的副歌的第一行都要重复
也不是所有的歌名一定是副歌的第一行
这首歌的歌名是里面的关键字
就是菊花
它里面歌词里面并没有出现菊花台这三个字
就像我青花瓷
它也不是副歌
你的泪光柔弱中带伤
惨白的月弯弯勾住过往
通常我创作这种比较所谓中国风的歌词
里面的关键字就会带来大家想象的画面感
很重要
惨白的月弯弯
月亮白色又惨白
那代表很伤心
所以呢月弯弯就很中国风的用语
然后再来夜太漫长
凝结成了霜
双这个字也是很
你可以说它是比较偏老派的字眼
现在的情歌很少用到双
可能是悲伤沮丧
还有可能
但是这首歌的画面感
它其实就适合用到霜
这个字很美
在雨轻轻弹朱红色的窗
我用朱红色
而不是用大红色
因为朱红这两个字又有宋词的意味
所以你去创作一首歌词的时候
记得你的遣词用语会有画面感
你要去经营画面感
所以同样的意境你用不一样的字
他的意境就会有想象空间了
然后最后是梦在远方化成一缕香
我用铝去当做香的单位
一缕香随风飘散
你的模样
各位同学
如果你要创作这种所谓中国风的歌词
记得不能全部都是类似仿宋词的那种文字
这样是不行的
玉里香诶就很宋慈的感觉
但是你的模样又把你拉回来了
我们并不是在填词牌名
你不能通篇都是那种呃
类似宋词或唐诗的那种遣词用语
但是你没有现代的字眼
那唱歌的人就很奇怪
好像是在唱
唱一首把宋词谱上流行音乐而写的歌
所以呢你看我的副歌
菊花残满地伤
哇这六个字就很很宋词
很中国风
但是你的笑容就拉回来了
任何现代流行音乐都会用到你的笑容
那泛黄是稍微又偏古代的花落人断肠就很古代
我的心思又很现代
一定要这样子交错使用
因为有一些同学他在写所谓中国风的歌
他没有注意到这个细节
有时候拿给我看
通篇都是仿宋词的结构
你这样子去填写歌词的时候很辛苦
因为你没有情绪了
你只有画面感
这个很重要
所以呢比较好的一首所谓中国风的歌
一定要有一些字句是宜古宜今
接下来第二段的副歌
北风乱夜未央
你的影子又把你拉回来了
剪不断
徒留我
孤单在湖面成霜
在这里分享一个小故事
有一次我去学校讲座
然后有个同学举手
我想说诶他肯定有什么问题要发我
结果不是他说老师你有首歌词写错了
我说哪哪一首哪一句
他说菊花台里面的徒留我孤单在湖面成双
他就跟我说
明明就孤单了
为什么能成双
然后所有同学有些还认为他讲的对
你知道吗
然后现场一阵骚动
我就说你要去经营文字的美感
有些是间接的
有些是有一层要想一下徒留我孤单在湖面成双
湖面是静止
想想看哦
你一个人坐在湖岸的旁边
然后湖面本身就是静止
你再看水里面的你
那不是成双了吗
你跟自己的倒影成双
这是更孤独了
就徒留我孤单在湖面成双
就是自己跟自己成双
并不是跟他思念的那个人
接下来再介绍菊花台里面的一段歌词
叫愁莫渡江
秋心拆两半
怕你上不了岸
一辈子摇晃
这什么意境呢
就是说愁这个字拆开来就是秋跟辛
他希望你不要过来了
但是他已经过来了
所以他怕他过来之后又上不了岸
就回不到现实里面
一辈子就在回忆里面跌宕
所以怕你上不了岸
一辈子摇晃
你去记忆文字的细节跟美感
让听歌的人要想一程才想到哦
原来是这样子
那这样子的歌词就是一篇好的歌词
因为呢我把旋律抽走了
我的文字还有被单独欣赏的美感
被单独咀嚼的空间
你太平白直叙的歌词
旋律一旦抽走了
那个纯文字根本就没有阅读的美感
一首好的歌词有个先决条件
就是不受音乐的干扰
旋律抽走之后
光阅读文字
他还有一个鉴赏的一种乐趣
或咀嚼的空间
或字里行间透露着一个意境
一个美感
那就是一篇笔
叫好的歌词
这首跟各位同学分享的天地龙鳞
他的作曲是王力宏老师
他是个专案
就是说故宫600年600年的一个算是主题曲吧
你想想看一个皇城建筑历经了600年的风雨
屹立不摇
这个很本身就很有历史的纵深感
所以那时候去经营这个文字的时候
我就去搜集一些资料
所以呢像泱泱华夏文明
因为紫禁城的一个建筑
它的分量
它的一个艺术上的一个建筑美
它就是华夏文明的呈现跟文化生根
这些都是有画面感的东西
然后寻龙林
但是你还在有个鼠标
所以天地龙鳞是经过讨论
而且他们喜欢龙鳞这个概念
然后把它赋予这整首歌去贯穿它
所以同学们记住
就是说你要记你一个好的歌词的时候
方方面面很多
有时候你要兼顾到画面感
有时候你要兼顾到用字的一个细腻度
那这些都是可以搭配的
他的副歌是一个韵脚
你看啊
这龙鳞却成金
铿锵落地
犹如碎冰
你看冰曾经跟龙林还有一片林
一片心
故事飘摇
我不忍听
这个副歌是一个韵脚
然后它的a one a two是一个韵脚
这江山我起笔民族血脉又几万里
几世纪600年里
龙的传人历经风雨
这金鸡中轴地亦无君子
气节不宜
九龙壁瓦上琉璃
历史从这衰落又崛起
他这是有变化
就是主歌跟副歌的韵脚不一样
这个是绝对可以的
甚至于我一直强调同一段的主歌你都还是可以
前面两行一个韵脚
后面两行一个韵脚
但是切记不要为了换韵脚而换韵脚
你觉得同格韵脚很顺
像刚刚的菊花台
基本上它是同格听觉韵脚
因为它有安跟on
那写的很顺
就直接写了
比如好像嗯好像换韵讲是种挑战
我一定要到副歌换个韵脚哦
不需要不需要
就说你当下落笔的当下觉得好像有点腻了
全部都是同韵脚
你就换觉得好像抒发的还可以
这样子的情感是你要的
这样子的画面感是你是对的
那就继续写下去
像情绪的字眼是我清醒等回音
因为我是最直截了当的人称代名词
所以不管你的歌如何的仿中国风
或是往中国风的方向发展
一定要你我他这种人声代名词会把情绪拉回来
就是你经营一个场景
一个空间
一个画面感
但是讲到感情
讲到情绪的时候
又有人声代名词进入到里面
这样子的一个布局跟安排
才是经营一首歌的一个正确的一种技术
这个其实接下来还有几堂课可以分析
那我这边先讲一小部分
就是说有时候我们一首歌
我们可以先经营他的画面感
然后有时候有情绪
所有的情绪最好是有在副歌
那画面感最好是在主歌
因为他先进来这个空间
处在这个空间的一个结构里面
然后到了副歌
然后旋律比较高亢的时候
记忆点比较深的时候
哎情绪的字眼进来了
所有情绪的字眼就可能就像人声带明这种
就是情绪的字眼
那这首歌呢我清醒
等回音这句话就是情绪的字眼
然后在九龙壁瓦上琉璃
这个就很画面感
你手各有九龙壁跟瓦瓦片的瓦琉璃
那这个是皇城的感觉了
是皇家的气息了
画面感的东西会让你的文字有空间
那有空间
你听歌的人感受的时候
就比较容易进入那个情绪
然后再辅助适当的情绪字眼
我举例来讲
还有首歌叫缘分一道桥
它是张艺谋导演的一个长城
一个电影的主题曲
这首歌也是跟王力宏老师合作的
那我分享两个段落
就是它里面有一句歌词是谈爱恨不能潦草
战鼓敲啊敲
用信任立下誓言
我来熬
他整段歌是压奥运
那记住哦
你看战鼓为什么用战鼓
是因为谈爱恨不能潦草
然后战鼓的铿锵有力去对仗他那个潦草
另外一个分享就是这缘分像一道桥
旌旗飘啊飘
同学们请注意哦
这里是用旌旗飘啊
飘上一大段是用战鼓敲啊敲
因为旌旗它可以有画面感插在桥上
所以一道桥旌旗迎风飘扬嘛
这缘分像一道桥
旌旗飘啊飘
你想走就请立马抽刀
爱一笔勾销
立马抽刀
为什么
因有桥上一段是桥
所以立马抽刀去呼应桥
他就很有画面感
你说缘分是一道桥
那你要走我就立马抽刀
爱就勾一笔
勾销了
就是你走你的我走我的了
这个就是文字去记忆的一种技巧
一种画面感
你要去呼应前一行
前一行的字句
下一段的内容就呼应前一行
那这样子的结构就是完整的
这个就是创作上一种必备的技术
那你们从歌词创作班所学到的都是技术
都是含金量很高的技术